this video is sponsored by the self-care
app fabulous the first 500 people to use
the link in the description will receive
25 off fabulous premium
Felix sat against a tree in a small
field about a mile into the woods behind
his family's house he had somewhat
recently developed a fondness for
spending time secluded in nature and he
loved studying and collecting plants and
minerals and whatever else he could find
often creating journals with drawings
and diagrams to identify and log his
findings he came to this specific tree
quite often whenever he wanted to clear
his head or make a big decision it was
isolated away from everyone and
everything Felix had just turned 18 and
was going off to University in the
coming fall he still had not yet fully
decided what he wanted to study though
and it was eating away at him he knew he
didn't have to decide right then and
then stick to it for the rest of his
life but he was the type of person who
once he chose something he was pretty
much all in on it and he knew that about
himself
Felix sat there against the tree and
thought to himself about his future who
he wanted to be and how he wanted to
live his life part of him wanted to
pursue something like botany and live a
simple life but another part of him
wanted something much greater to be
truly successful renowned by the world
and history he wanted to be someone who
was known and remembered
before he knew it the day grew old and
Felix grew tired he looked up at the sky
as the light blue became a gradient of
colors soon to be Darkness he looked
around him at the Spring Leaves rustling
on the trees and the budding flowers
trembling in the wind he took a deep
breath and closed his eyes
[Music]
when Felix opened his eyes he saw a
woman she was standing at a tree
opposite him maybe 50 yards away her
face was angled slightly and pressed up
against the tree with one of her hands
kind of cupped around her eye she
appeared to be looking into it she was
dressed in all white and had a strange
lightness about her she was old but not
elderly her face was tight but pretty
Felix had never seen anyone around this
area before so he was immediately
startled and confused he quickly got up
and began walking home
hey yell the woman Felix paused and
hesitantly turned around toward her the
woman was somehow right up near him now
maybe two arms lengths away
hi
Felix said apprehensively you don't have
to leave just because of me said the
woman I just like coming out here to
think that's a strange coincidence Felix
thought to himself no it's fine I was
just heading home okay suit yourself
Felix turned around and kept walking
what were you thinking about the woman
continued unprompted Felix turned around
again
why you seem stressed maybe I can help
I've been around a while
um you know school life in general I
guess
hmm said the woman what about it I guess
I'm trying to decide what I want to do
what I want to go to school for and
doing life and everything
well what do you want ask the woman
I want to be successful I know that and
I want to be important I want the world
to know me and remember me hmm said the
woman she stood quietly for a moment
look over here for a minute I want to
show you something the woman walked over
to the tree Felix was sitting at Felix
followed somewhat hesitantly
when they arrived the woman pointed at
the tree staring at it intensely Felix
was confused as he looked on at the tree
then the woman then back at the tree
suddenly the woman approached the tree
and placed her finger into the face of
it it went right through the ground
shook with a brief but violent jolt
Felix found the whole thing kind of
disturbing
the woman walked back away from the tree
looked at Felix and then pointed at what
was now a small hole about the size of a
coin what's that Felix asked look said
the woman Felix approached the tree
hesitantly and looked inside as he
approached the view inside the hole grew
larger and larger almost distorting the
tree and creating a growing fisheye
perspective like a peephole on a door on
the inside he saw himself and the woman
as if from another person's perspective
behind them he saw himself from third
person looking into the tree with the
woman standing behind him what is that
Felix asked is concertingly moving away
follow me said the woman the woman began
walking into the woods compelled by
curiosity in an inexplicable Comfort
Felix followed her while they were
walking Felix blurted out can you go
into that into what the little whole
thing no why not
you'll die
when the two reached another seemingly
arbitrary tree the woman stopped She
approached it and poked three holes in a
horizontal line and then stepped back
Felix followed her lead and looked
inside the first hole he saw a man who
looked to be in his 20s or 30s he looked
familiar but Felix couldn't quite pin
down exactly where he had seen him from
before the man was sitting at a desk
alone working it appeared to be a large
office with big Windows it was nighttime
and you could see the skyline of a city
behind him the man appeared to be deeply
stressed Felix backed away from the hole
who is that he asked
you
Felix looked in again and recognized
himself now
you are one of the few people capable of
immense greatness the woman said in a
much more intense focused tone your
traits and abilities will mix just right
to allow you to climb the ranks of the
business world and you will become one
of the most prominent business magnates
and product developers in human history
you will be revered by the world in your
lifetime you will be remembered for a
long time after it
the woman pointed at the second hole
Felix looked inside and saw an older man
in his 40s or 50s he was on a large
stage receiving what looked like some
sort of an award he was wearing a
strange tuxedo unlike anything Felix had
ever seen before a massive crowd was
applauding him a woman and two children
stood at the front of it the man smiled
and pointed at them then he smiled and
pointed at the rest of the crowd a
moment passed and the man got off the
stage and went up to the woman and two
children in the front they appeared to
be his family he whispered in the
woman's ear his lips reading I have to
catch that flight now the woman looked
disappointed as the man left with what
looked like a small team of security is
that that's me too Felix asked the woman
as he pulled his face away
yes a little bit older
without being instructed Felix looked
into the third hole it was a classroom
filled with students the classroom
looked strange mostly empty with Sleek
White Walls and Floors the students were
using some sort of device that displayed
out in front of them like a holographic
textbook on their displays were text and
an image of Felix in his 50s
is that well after your lifetime
interrupted the woman
Felix began to feel an Indescribable
sense of Pride relief and excitement for
himself and his future he smiled tightly
and his shoulders raised
you will be this said the woman but you
will dedicate your entire life to your
career to your business to your legacy
okay Felix said figuring as much no you
don't understand the woman continued
you will sacrifice everything your free
time most of your social life most of
your love life and family life almost
all of your leisure and peace and quiet
just about everything else will fall to
the Wayside but it is guaranteed you
will be this known by the world and
remembered by history
what about like more of a balance Felix
interrupted there is no balance when one
side of the scale requires everything
from you
Felix paused so is is this It Felix said
as he gestured out and around him hoping
that perhaps the woman was an indication
of something Beyond this life follow me
said the woman continuing to walk a
little further into the woods and up a
hillside the woman stopped at a large
Boulder Felix was exhausted the Knight
was taking over the sky again the woman
created a hole this time in the face of
the rock she stepped away and pointed
toward It Felix approached and looked in
inside Felix saw nothing
the only dimension of space he could
make out was from faint light beams that
seemed to be coming from what looked
like stars in the distance
what is that Felix asked as he pulled
his head away
that's here a short time into the future
relatively speaking
the woman pointed at the ground but
there's nothing Felix said I know
where is everything
where everything goes
but what happened to Earth what didn't
happen to Earth
the woman poked another hole in the
boulder right above the previous one
Felix knew what to do by now inside this
one he saw everything in a violent
rupture of perspective he was pulled
from his myopic View and thrust outward
into an Indescribable unrestrained view
of everything free from Time free from
space he saw the waltz of waves in the
Poetry of particles the discotheque of
dimensions and the emancipation of
energy the dance of Decay and the pain
of progress he saw nothing in everything
intertwined like a serpent consuming its
tail with reason and absurdity excreting
out from it finally Felix saw himself
amidst it all an infinitesimal blemish
on a speck that if it didn't exist
nothing would be different at all his
tininess was as inconceivable as the
universe's vastness
Felix pushed himself away holding his
upper stomach and breathing heavily the
woman waited a minute
come on let's go back now
the two arrived back at the tree where
they had started the hole in the tree
was gone now but the woman made two
final new ones Felix exhausted now
unable to imagine what else she could
possibly be showing him slowly and
reluctantly approached and looked inside
he saw himself again in his 30s or 40s
but this time he was walking in the
woods with two other people around the
same age they were wearing relatively
casual outdoorsy clothing They Carried
large futuristic test tubes and what
looked like digital magnifying glasses
they seemed happy
Felix looked into the second hole it was
him again still around the same age a
little older maybe he was playing with
children in the front yard of a house in
what looked like the countryside a woman
sat in the background on the porch of
the small home a moment passed and then
a car drove up and another family got
out and joined them
Felix pulled his head away
is that is that also me it is
I'm confused I thought you said I was
going to be
what about my destiny every Destiny is
made of decisions every decision is made
with a goal in mind your destiny is only
what you do you can choose not to
Felix paused trying to wrap his head
around everything
the weight and absurdity of the whole
experience knocked him to the ground
when you see everything you realize how
much is really nothing and when you see
nothing you realize what is really
everything
you said you wanted to be successful I
can see everything anytime any place and
I do not know what this means only you
do
Felix leaned up against the tree and
laid back for a moment he looked up at
the night sky breathed in deeply and
closed his eyes
so said the woman
what are you going to do
[Music]
thank you so much for watching this
video was sponsored by the number one
self-care app fabulous
perhaps one of the most important but
difficult things we can do in life is
understand and control ourselves the one
may conquer a thousand times a thousand
men in battle yet he indeed is the
noblest Victor who conquers himself said
the Buddha subduing the noise of the
world and the inner chatter of the Mind
conquering oneself and setting and
accomplishing goals we personally deem
valuable is no easy task though fabulous
however helps make this process much
easier by breaking down long-term goals
into small tasks trackable habits and
daily routines that actually stick
whether your goals are tangible things
like eating healthier or sleeping better
or more abstract things like developing
better gratitude or Focus fabulous
functions like a personalized digital
coach using principles from Behavioral
Science that help you define develop and
stick to routines making your goals more
attainable and the process more
rewarding if you're someone who just
wants help tracking and sticking to
individual habits you can use fabulous
more self-guided habit tracking of
approach and pick from more than 100
habits or create your own and then use
fabulous notifications tracking function
and other features or if you would
benefit from a more immersive experience
with extra guidance and insights on best
practices towards your goals you can use
fabulous dedicated program approach and
use the behavioral change programs habit
coaching programs guided experiences and
content Journeys for additional help
along the way no matter who you are how
your mind works or what you want your
daily life to feel like fabulous
provides a unique rewarding experience
that can help you turn just about any
goal into a daily reality start building
toward that ideal daily routine today by
clicking the link in the description
below the first 500 people to use the
link will get 25 percent off fabulous
premium with fabulous premium you can
create an unlimited number of habits and
take part in all programs and exercises
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]